eccolo questo sì che è un gioco da fare
eccoci doveva felice chi metri di
risonanza benissimo allora io devo dire
gravissimo che fosse un sta dando della
pipa mi sta dando l'artico io l'ho
sentito mi offende in pentola per
qualche come sigilli da qui lei cosa ma
stia tranquillo guarda allora guardi che
questa parte qui è veramente semplice ma
sì ma lo sarà mai finito questo gioco no
non l'ho mai finito però i suoi migliori
chiedo che non è vero che ho visto che
ha visto i miei video quindi ho servito
ad evitare gli spoiler no lei non sa
come rapidi questo giorno live sono
vergine signor gatto lo dobbiamo finire
è finito ecco qua ma come noi non siamo
toccabili uno all'anno che i magi il
casinò bisogna capire ma io mi aspettavo
come minimo la possibilità di parma di
coli in questo casino sarebbe ma ci si
poteva dare una mano no bastone sul
bastone sarebbe finito nel ma si tolga
che lei è lento e aqua non capisco chi
si sono vallo e qui è praticamente un
reskin potevano metterlo dove vado vado
avanti io lasci dietro l'altro e leno e
dico questa cosa provate entrare in una
partita con altre persone prima che lei
sa che se si vince questo gioco almeno
50 volte cosa impossibile e spunta la
pentola d'oro
ok è la gente che gioca online è tutta
con la pentola dove non ce n'è uno con
la pentola nera infatti siamo gli unici
dio le spoglie ora anche che possiamo
citare le si può citare come si città
salve
è come quali superato ma come brown lei
ma gara comunque non è non è male guarda
che arrivare qua all'inizio se l'ha
fatto poche volte non è male lei a lei è
una prova abbastanza volte per decidere
di chiudere il gioco
ok chiaro bene ho certo sono arrivato
alla parte quella del scala
nell'edificio dai la sma di già la
spagna per prima ma io faccio questo
senza fare altro nella vita su sono
emozionato sono caduto sono di nuovo al
caffè signor gatto questo è mio lavoro
da anni almeno quello eccoci allora
questa è la parte verano in questa è
veramente semplice copro classi lo sono
solo come si fa a guardi oppure di
guardare agli spin the runner la vita a
roma fin qui ci sono arrivato io ho
provato per cui io mi son fermato dopo
il barbecue dopo eva ama e pina che
troppo no fanno andare avanti signoria
tua faccia è certo che si può andare che
vedo che i romani insieme pensavo fosse
molto più avanti e dico magari non lo
raggiungiamo in un video ma invece
secondo me ce la facciamo però stia
attento che da lì cadere poi all'inizio
è un attimo è lo sciopero c'è anche il
cartello in italiano tra l'altro lo
scritto attenzione capitali maledizione
piano piano ma lei era la star
tranquillo è veramente una botte di
ferro
eccoci qua il barbecue in una botte di
ferro sul serio è veramente un casino
provenga qua venga qui si obietta ma
l'ha mangiata lei salma è padrone un
chip non è un centro di guardo
sviluppatore lo ha previsto ea previste
non solo presso sognato ma lei vuole
insegnarmi i giochi stupito guardi se
hai mette il martello esattamente dove
non messo in questo momento e si inclina
un po e poi tira tutta su è prova un po
di volta dovrebbe aggrapparsi a quella
scala
può farlo mentre lo faccio di tanto non
c'è il body collisione ok
guardi che bravo l'ho fatto subito venga
qui ok si tira su pian piano mi abbia
portato prima a posto c'è sorbetto
perpetrato dai venti effetti che ci ha
paura di lei un nome nuovo
seguo a me lo sono perché è chi segue
non mi segua scherzavo questo cadendo ok
allora qua si attacca qui così esa nel
mondo si non così non mi guardi per
cortesia che sono percepite in emozioni
si attacca qua e poi si attacca la
videocamera a sinistra mentre avevo ma
come succeda aveva non è vero come cosa
a destra ma se è vero oppure fa anche
esatto può fare anche così come sta
facendo la va bene esatto bravissimo lei
è bravo che sono subivano vada su come
facile dai quali non c'è l'ultima fannie
mae kakà carta quasi a parte ma il
quadro è tangibile
non lo tenga no chiedevo ok non è tanto
dire venga venga a o mi sa che non è
abbastanza
ok curva ter arriverci no aspetti ma
faccia lei allora ma faccia lei ma non
le dico niente
lei è bravo e faccia lei deve tirare ma
resista signor gara scivola scivola
perché non mi fa spiegare un attimo ac
edifici sia questa parte perché qua non
scivola da dalla seconda in poi scivola
quindi lei le varie proprio come questo
scivola no è perfetto questo questo è
ancora in pieno questo c'è gola da paura
lei faccia quello che faccio io poi
guardi prevediamo un casino e sembra
farsi si legge noi sappiamo che lei si
attacca si si avvicina
e poi gira tutto alla fine piano piano
così e si appoggia
guardi che si scivola e veramente
difficile sembra è una cara gatti alyson
è vero se non glielo spiega vera di
kiefer siano rogeruan riguarda la
famiglia corno se devo tirarmi su anche
quindi non mi corvino non credo sia
fattibile non devo fare la stessa cosa
guardi guardi al santone guardi ecco e
poi si attacca fuori questa parte devi
fare piano scherzavo
e già era giusto venga qua rifarli
faccia come diversi atteso è veramente
semplice questa cosa si è fatta piano si
è fatta veloce non ce la farà mai a fino
alla terza roccia può farlo anche
abbastanza in velocità media l'ultima
deve fare piano conti ma deve proprio
fare piano dove venga proprio doveva
dov'è andato venga venga non ho mai
capito ragionavo ok e no perché voglio
vederla è però scivola anche se mi può
giudicare né che professore guardali se
dice vabbè detto che hai capito no
dimostrazioni siamo arrivati signor
gatto a posto per arrivato ci siamo ora
qua siam alla tower tower è molto
semplice in realtà sembrano ecco sembra
difficile ma è semplice pantera venga
pecora arriviamo allora mi piace vada su
non come ho fatto io o meglio solo sopra
me piace anch'io quando avrebbe
riuscirvi piste libero sono già usciti
quindi a me sono usciti allora posto
lei non è vero non mi ha tolto io vedevo
il mouse e pensavo fosse non doveva
perché vedere che io non volevo farlo
questo video però dai curiosi e video è
la frase che ho sentito fin troppo
signor gatto venga qui professor stato
voi avete costretto io sai come qua è
vero che questo settore ragazzi questa
questa parte io la trovo praticamente
quasi lapidi fitch è del tutto il gioco
perché ai colori su e perché non c'è
proprio per il pericolo di cadere ma non
si riesce mai ad aggrapparsi mai
certo è difficile aggrapparsi non mi
ricordo mai come faccio quando lo faccio
dico a ecco come si faceva ai premi ma
non solo e il secchio allora lei è mai
arrivato qua se no vabbè ovvia ma no
neanche qui c'e non ho mai città però
mai visto cosa succede in questo gioco
no no non sono completamente fa notare
sul dono wright snake anche se ma c'è
scritto di noi è ma pressoché tutto al
contrario faccia lei prima però aspetti
venga poi poggi sono il martello senza
andare giù subito che le spiego allora
oggi un po lo deve poggiare su è ok
perfetta parità o ma mi sta portando
all'inizio la forca più non lo sapeva
l'avevo intuito dal cartello non lo
sapessero se lo sapevo lo facevo è che
colmi di stare lì perché non può
arrivare dove vuole arrivare ok ecco qua
e là dal cero dietro perché deve fare
tutto il giro particolare ok ce l'ho
fatta ok non deve fare così deve
aggrapparsi questo aggrappato ritirassi
su così che però è difficile avere io
cado allora qual è questa allora questa
è la rice mountain deve semplicemente
incastrare il martello tirassi su non
c'è un vero non glielo so spiegare è
molto difficile lo faccia con isteria
bravo bravo continui con tv bravo
continua esista insista brasile si sta
esista insista così bravissimo ti massa
perché perché ho inventato il dpr al
massimo sto usando tutta la scrivania
per forza lei è messo meglio usa 8 km
maria bravi tutti così cosa c'è qua
uscito la cura e quelli che non era
facile riuscito veramente a ma vuoi
vedere che lei non si dava l'ho spinta
perché si fermava per via della
scrivania ma per forza così perché la
sera normale non so un transatlantico
fatta ce l'ho fatta ce l'ha fatta di
nuovo il cavo del mouse questo finale
non so come aspettarla lo sa se io
arrivo il finale non eri come aspettando
devo finire per forza ma lei finisca
come definire io faccio fitta ma
vincendo su youtube guarda il suo video
ci prova allora promoserio qua non sono
stato serio finora ma cipro ma è
comunque molto difficile
ok a quello che vuole e fa quello che
vuole lui qui
[Musica]
ce l'ho fatta
il signor gatto sono stato molto bravo
anche lei comunque io dico la verità
sono abbastanza orgoglioso perché
comunque non è semplice non è semplice
neanche con i chip quindi poteva andare
molto peggio
[Musica]